Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two David Pakman.
This is an interesting voicemail with with
a historical question. How did the American
right wing get so crazy? Listen to this.
Speaker 6: Hi, David, this is Josh from
Maryland. Yeah, and my question is just regarding
the conservative culture in the United States,
how do we get here? How do we get to a point
where 40 percent of the country believes a
wild conspiracy theories believes a centrist
politician like Joe Biden is a communist?
Yep. And there's a massive misinformation
media industry. All right. Thank you.
Speaker 1: The answer is a very long one. And
I've talked about this before. I spoke about
this even with Noam Chomsky not not that long ago.
And if you. Wow. I mean, it's like how do you even
you almost have to go back to the creation of
the United States. But to save you the really
long version, first of all, you can Google anti
intellectual ism, pseudo intellectual ism, United
States. Eighteen hundreds. There's a big A.N.
pseudo intellectual movement in the eighteen
hundreds, which you could say kind of is the
original underpinnings or catalysts for what
we see today in a more modern political sense.
You kind of have this story that I've told before
and if you've heard it before and you don't want
to hear it again, I apologize. But you initially
saw big reactions to the civil rights movement
in the late 50s, early 60s that started to lead
to people's emotions, bringing them to believe and
want things politically. That really made no sense
then that led into the Reagan era and
people starting to fall for stories
that reinforce their preexisting beliefs, like
about welfare queens and so on and so forth
that ultimately led into the Clinton era. We're
skipping some steps, the Clinton era of the early
90s, where in 1994, Newt Gingrich took over as
speaker of the House and sort of went full bore
on this idea that we might not really need policy.
The Republicans of 94 still did some policy,
but they did a lot of character assassination and
personal attacks that started to go to the next
level, the next step on the unhinged ladder under
George W. Bush. George W. Bush is kind of a sleepy
doofus, for lack of a better term, further created
this idea that even though he's a sleepy doofus,
this is what it means to be patriotic. And a lot
of people who were quite ignorant rallied around
Bush, rallied around the Iraq war, rallied around
attacking Iraq because mostly Saudi men attacked
us on 9/11. Barack Obama as the first black
president, a half black individual, of course,
basically got us off policy altogether as far
as Republicans are concerned. And just on,
this guy isn't even American. This guy's a
Muslim or Muslim, as some of them like to say.
And we came that that's when the the the even
mere pretense of caring about policy disappeared
and then Trump and the Kuhnen and et cetera. So
you can trace it back to the start of the civil
rights movement in fifty eight, you can trace it
back to a.. And pseudo intellectual ism in the
eighteen hundreds. You could even go back further
if you were so inclined. But it is a very the fact
that it's such a long history is what makes me
pessimistic about the idea that we're going to
solve it any time soon. On today's Bonas show,
we'll talk about the Ben and Jerry's ice cream
fiasco. We'll talk about a big opioid settlement,
which we're going to have a lawyer on to talk
about next week. And we will talk about a gender
reveal party that sparked a wildfire leading to 30
different criminal charges. I'm basically against
gender reveal parties and I'm in a hot take alert.
I'll talk about why on today's Bono show. Sign
up at Join Pakman Dotcom and I'll see you then.